Alright here it comes,
and 3,2,1, action!
♪♪
They created this whole
crazy epic world.
This season everyone is
changing and evolving.
It’s just real exciting.
I think people are going to be
blown away,
when they see what
season two looks like.
Boom, uggghhhh, love my job.
With season two it’s amazing
what we’ve pulled off.
It’s not an easy thing to create
these huge epic worlds.
These civilizations.
These kingdoms.
Let us not wait until they knock
down our gates.
I say we open it right now
and protect what is ours
at all costs.
For season two we wanted to come
down off the mountains
and see what life was like in
what used to be the cities.
Leaving season one and coming
into a city and seeing its decay
after six hundred years, it’s a
whole different look,
you know, he’s crawling
back into Hell.
We are moving along
geographically and we come to
places that would be cities,
in the aftermath,
all those hundreds
of years in the future.
How cold is it J?
It’s negative 20.
(laughs)
I like the cold. I don’t know,
I always end up in the cold
or in water.
We took that destroyed
city aesthetic and really
ran with it.
Just the expanse of it
is pretty spectacular.
The main streetwhere we’ve
turned cars on their end and
stacked them to be the wall and
then we used quite literally
a bus as the gate.
It was quite a sight actually.
We always want to kinda make the
scope and scale and
The Hearn allowed that because
of the geography of this coal
fired plant that’s just massive.
This is one of the coolest sets
I’ve ever been on in my life.
Look at that. Look over there.
It’s amazing.
I’ve never been in a
building that big.
There are some shots in there
that are just like unbelievable.
Awesome.
I just got drooled
on by Bautista.
Awesome. Awesome. Awesome.
A lot of the things we build are
beautiful,
but there is also a
lot of logic built into it.
We have a full crew of artists
who build everything for the
show in house, which is really
unique for television.
I just love that we can put
things in there that we know
from our time and they have
become something else.
I think that’s brilliant.
It forces you to think outside
the box and use your other
senses for fabrics, by touch
it is the texture,
and then also does
it make sound.
My queen.
This is basically me being a six
year old boy. Dream come true.
Best, best outfit ever.
I’m going to be a samurai.
Jason would be the
quintessential warrior.
In all factions.
My love for Japanese culture
happen to coincide with
Jason’s love for
Japanese culture
and he always wanted to have
this kind of influence
and so I thought,
hey let’s do samurai.
My whole life I wanted to play a
samurai.
I love Yojimbo and Seven Samurai
and so I always wanted to play a
character like that.
When you see him emerge in that,
along with the robes,
the kimono and the hakama.
He looks powerful.
(Inaudible) Dream job.
I had all of these made for me.
Look at that. Woo!
Jason loves his weapons.
Yeah!
I had a dream of different
things I wanted to make.
Picked out the antlers I wanted,
picked out the style of knife
that I wanted.
Finally it’s here.
Woah! Look at that!
These swords were made in
Hawaii.
The rest pretty much in Texas.
That is perfect.
Everything from the weapons to
the costume department to the
sets department. Everyone really
wants to elevate this season.
There’s too many of them.
Advance!
In the world of See you can be
the Queen.
You can be a leader of a tribe.
You can be a warrior.
Each individual is treated as
an equal in our show.
Look at this.
This is why I love movies.
All these beautiful people,
that make it possible.
I get to travel the world, and
meet all types of artists,
that get to build
worlds like this.
We all come together to make
something that hopefully changes
your perspective and be
compassionate to
other people’s lives.
I love it.
Baba!
Now!
The level of ambition on this
show is through the roof.
This whole season has been
incredible.
I am a father.
I am a husband.
I am your friend.
I am Baba Voss
and I am fighting for your
freedom
until the day that I die.
Boom.